I Define love as what you are willing to  endure to keep something it's like man  he must love that car because that  thing's a piece of crap he won't get rid  of it he must love that somebody loves  his kids they go they pick him up at  work they do all these things for their  kids and they're not getting anything  back the extent to which you're willing  to endure is the extent to which you  love something and to the same degree  you can think about the dark side of  that people love their addiction which  is why they're willing to endure so much  pain to keep it for me I so desperately  loved and desired to be successful  because of my own past that I was  willing to endure everything short of  death to get there